Please join me in giving a
warm welcome to Amanda Cohen.
Thank you for that lovely
introduction. Of course. Amanda,
thanks so much for coming. I know we're
all really excited to have you. Um,
so let's just start about learning a
little bit more about your background.
How did you know you want it to be a chef
and eventually opened up a restaurant
and a cookbook?
I didn't know any of that.
I still don't know if I know any of that.
I'm not sure what I want to do when
I grow up. Um, you know, I had,
I really loved cooking as a kid.
I'm from a really big family. Uh,
I had four older siblings and there's
about a five year gap between,
uh, my nearest sibling to me in age. And
one day all my siblings sort of ended up,
you know,
they were all in college and my mom
basically turned to me and my dad and was
like, yeah, I'm done. I'm not
cooking anymore. We were like, okay.
My Dad was like, yeah, I guess
I'll just have lunch at the office.
I don't know what he did. And I was like,
yeah, and I'm 13, like I've got to eat.
She was like, yeah, you're going
to have to figure it out. Um,
and I did and I really liked to cook.
So every night I would,
after school I would go home and cook and,
and I just fell in love with that,
that time in the kitchen and how
much fun it was to play with food.
And then I sort of forgot about it. Uh,
I went to college, I came to New York,
I went to Nyu, I went through school,
I traveled a bunch afterwards.
I lived in Hong Kong for two years.
I lived in La for a year and I
was really floundering and I,
what I really wanted to do in
my life was travel and not work.
And then I realize that, well,
you know, nothing's free.
So I had to have a skill and I literally
had no skills. And I was like, well,
maybe if I go to cooking school,
I can travel with this skill and I
like to cook enough. So, you know,
I'll learn how to cook and then I
can go anywhere in the world, uh,
and use this great skill of mine.
So I came back to New York and I went to
cooking school and I started cooking in
the city and I actually really never
traveled again. I've been here ever since.
And that was about maybe 20 years ago.
Uh,
and even at that time as I was cooking,
I didn't,
I didn't know this was my passion. It's
what I wanted to do. I just liked it.
I liked the culture and kitchens.
I really liked sort of exploring,
uh, textures and flavors
with food. I like the hours.
I like sort of just the
whole crazy environment. Uh,
and I kept going and going and
going until one day I realized,
Oh shit, this is what I do. I
guess, you know, now, you know,
10 years into this I can call
myself a cook and a chef. Um,
and then I had had a series of
jobs, uh, some which I liked,
some of which I hated,
but I kind of hit a point in
my career where I couldn't,
I couldn't go any further. Uh, I had
sort of stayed in the vegetarian world,
um, and there weren't really any other
vegetarian restaurants. I could go cook.
I had sort of cooked at them
all in the city and I, you know,
I had this choice I had to make,
which was either, you know,
stay where I was in my career or start
back at the beginning and, you know,
be a line cook and a
mainstream restaurant, cook a
lot more meat and you know,
rise to the ranks that
way. Or I could, you know,
say screw it all and
start my own restaurant.
And I had actually kept working for
other people and then I kind of got fired
from a lot of jobs and I realized that,
oh,
maybe my only option is to
work for myself. Obviously
I don't like other bosses.
And so that's when I opened
the restaurant. Well,
that's an awesome story. Um, how
was opening your first restaurant?
Could you walk us through
what that really is like? Um,
it's sort of like going to hell
and never getting out of it.
And you think you're at like the last
circle and then you discovered there's
actually an eighth circle of hell.
And that's just like the first day I'm
opening the restaurant. And it was,
it was really, really hard. Uh, you know,
you think you know everything and you
know, you're like, oh, I, you know,
I'll figure this out as I go along.
But I've worked in restaurants for
long enough so I know how this works.
And as it turns out, you know,
nothing. And just, uh, you know,
I've opened a second restaurant since
and I had the second time, I was like,
you know, everything, I've got this
under control and I'm still like, fuck,
how do I not know anything? How do I keep
throwing this up over and over again?
Um, the, you know, they say that opening,
you know, chefs have really big egos.
I gotta tell you though,
opening a restaurant will just crush
that over and over and over again.
So the first one was really
hard. Uh, it was small.
It was 350 square feet.
I had about maybe $300,000 was my budget,
which, you know, 350 square
feet. Sounds like a lot.
It sounds like it should be
the right amount of money. Uh,
I had an awful contractor. He
really, really screwed us over. Uh,
he took all my money basically
and didn't do a lick of work,
and then we had to bring
in a second contractor.
And if you've ever built anything,
you sort of know that that's
the worst thing you can do,
because then nobody has to take
responsibility for anything.
So when the plumbing goes wrong, the
second contractors like, Oh yeah, sorry,
that's not my problem. And you're
like, yeah, but you're my contract.
And they're like, yeah, but the
first contractor put it in all right.
And he's like, so it's going to cost, you
know, you know, $500,000 and you're like,
well, I need a bathroom. So. Okay. Um,
and you know, the build out was
supposed to take three months.
It ended up taking a year, uh, and
it costs us instead of costs 300,000,
it cost us $700,000 for 350 square feet.
And the place was still
like crappy. Like, you know,
people would walk in and be like,
what's this little like, you know,
like crap hole in the Middle East village.
And I'd be like,
but it's such an expensive crop to
see that. It took me like, you know,
like a year to get the floors
level and they'd be like, yeah,
but that's still rolling downhill.
I know. Well, I tried. Um,
and then when we actually opened,
uh,
because everybody had really
sort of, uh, not done their job,
we opened without gas.
And so we spent the first six
months without gas cooking
on, um, like, you know,
like easy bake appliances. I mean,
you made a teeny, tiny little griddle,
a teeny tiny little fryer. I've
run with like a toaster oven. Um,
and wasn't even one of those,
I don't know if anybody watches like
real housewives of New York where I been,
it wasn't even a fancy title, but like
that it was like, you know, it's like,
it's really like an easy bake oven and,
and so we had to really struggle through
that and eventually we got gas and we
had sort of set the restaurant up to fail.
And that's a really weird way to
write up a budget. But I was like,
I don't know if anybody's going to want
to come and eat my food. Uh, you know,
we're,
we're to do vegetarian,
but we're really going to
focus on vegetables and I
who knows who's going to be
out there. You don't want to come eat.
And we had set it up so that, you know,
if worse came to worse, I can be the only
one in the restaurant running it. Um,
you know,
that it seems really roomy if it's one
person doing all the jobs and the 350
square foot restaurant.
And what happened actually is we got
really busy and we were really lucky.
So within the first couple of months
we started really filling up and then
filling up way too much.
Uh,
and we kept having to hire more staff
and trying to get as many guests into the
restaurant as possible. So in sort of a
normal restaurant you would want to do,
if you have 18 seat, the
most you'd really, really
want to do is about 50. Yeah.
It's about two and a half turns plus a.
And we started doing
about 65 people at night,
which meant we were doing three and
a half turns and the restaurant just
collapsed. It couldn't withstand that
many people. And I had too many staff.
And you think with that and a number of
people coming in that you would actually
be making money and it would be a
financial success, but it's not. Uh,
we actually were, I'm not sure the
restaurant really ever made any money.
Wow. What a great story
they always about. Yeah,
we talked about being scrappy at Google
and using those easy Vaco flights is
definitely a applies over here.
So when you think about,
um,
you know,
the landscape of New York restaurants
or even just restaurants in general,
a lot of the trends are moving towards
this vegetable focused cuisine.
How do you think of new ideas? How do you
keep them fresh? How do you know that,
you know, good, I do a lot of drugs
and I don't, you know,
that's, that's a real, it's a,
it's a hard question because how
to, people are always like, oh,
how do you come up and doing
dishes? And honestly, I'm
like, I don't know. You know,
like I think of a vegetable,
I think of a flavor.
I think of a place on the menu where we
need to do something and then we'd go
through a lot of testing.
So whatever,
and the idea is in my
head at the beginning,
it looks totally different when it goes
out to a customer. Three months later,
after all the testing, uh,
you know, we have, uh, uh,
Broccoli dish. We have these Broccoli hot
dogs. This is an easy example. And we,
I knew I wanted to do something with
Broccoli and we hadn't had this sort of
smoked cauliflower dish on the menu.
People loved it.
It had been on for about
two years and I was like,
it's time to for that to go to
the island of retire dishes,
we need to get something new in.
And Broccoli was the right vegetable
because it has this sort of same sort of
half.
So it was filling a position on the
menu and I really wanted to do something
with Barbecue Broccoli and
we had sort of pulled out,
we pulled off the all the stocks off
the Broccoli so that there was just this
one single Florette on a
very low on its long stock.
And we were going to like
grill that and I don't know,
it was going to get slathered in a
barbecue sauce and I want her to like five
different barbecue sauces and make
it really provisional and you know,
have soft white bread and
make it Broccoli bread.
And I kept testing this and kept
testing this and it was disgusting.
It was like the most disgusting
thing we've ever made.
And the Broccoli bread was like foul.
It was like my staff was like,
stop making us eat this.
And I was like, no,
but I think this one's a little bit
better. And they're like, it's not,
it's just not.
Um,
but we had all these sort of components
and we had made the Broccoli Bun,
we're getting made the
Broccoli bread into a bun.
And I had sort of had a temper tantrum,
which I'd like to say I'm exaggerating,
but really I had had a temper tantrum
in the middle of the restaurant.
We like been working on it for months,
so it was a Sunday.
And I literally just took everything
and threw it in the garbage, uh,
and maybe through some things at the
wall and broke some dishes. But, uh,
the, I sort of really,
this, I would happen,
I looked in the garbage and the stock of
Broccoli sort of fell into the bun and
I was like, oh, well, that
looks like a Broccoli hot dog.
So we went back to the drawing table and
we stopped making the Broccoli buttons.
Uh, we made a, the soft white Japanese,
uh, milk bread, really, really soft,
as close to sort of like a fake button
as you can possibly make. And you know,
then we have our broccoli stalk in the
middle and the Broccoli Sauerkraut that
we put on top and this mustard sauce and
dehydrated broccoli raab chips with a
little vinegar powder. And you know,
the dish sort of rolled out from there.
Now that dish actually gave birth
to another dish because, uh,
so the problem with the Broccoli hot
dog is we have that one center stock of
Broccoli. Right? But you get like
eight cups of Broccoli Florets.
So it's the little place. We just ate
a lot of broccoli for our family meal.
But I mean,
you have to imagine and be like everyday
if you guys went to the cafeteria.
And the only thing that was
there was broccoli verbal. Um,
and we still couldn't get rid of it.
Like we had too much. And so we actually,
I tried to offer it to all the shops in
the neighborhood and people would take
like a court here or you
know, a gallon there. Um,
and then we tried to actually give
it away to the restaurants in the
neighborhood and be like, oh look
family meal. And they're like,
yeah we can't eat that much broccoli.
And then I actually put up an ad on
Craig's list giveaway the Broccoli and
that's how we finally started really
getting rid of it. There was one woman,
she came and she would get like she would
take it all and it would be like a lot
like the gallons and gallons
of it every week. We're like,
what is she doing with it?
So,
and we couldn't actually make
a dish with the Broccoli yet,
little dirt candy cause
we didn't have the space.
And so everything that we did at the
little one was really based on the space
that we had. How many dishes was the
amount of space we had in the fridge,
how much alcohol we served with,
how much space we had in the drawers
under the bank cat where we stored it. Um,
but at the new place we have a,
we have the,
we have the space, we have
walk ins and fridges. So we
were like, okay, well we are,
we've got to figure out something
to do with the Broccoli.
And that's how we came up with probably
our most popular dish at the moment,
which is our Korean Fried Broccoli,
which is a deep fried Broccoli dish.
And it's addictive and people
come all over to have it.
And then they have a second one, they
have a third one. I'm like, Oh my God,
I'm going to have to pay for your hospital
bills cause they're going to die. Um,
and amazingly we still have too much
broccoli and I'm still giving it away to a
restaurant down the street,
but not as much broccoli ice cream maybe.
Very cool. Um, so as a
chef and restauranteur,
you've also done some really amazing
things in terms of eliminating tipping.
So how did you come to that
decision? What made you, you know,
what were your key drivers and how
did you react to some of the press and
people's results yet?
So
I came to it for a couple
of different reasons. Um,
the first was about three,
four years ago,
I put out an ad for a new cook at dirt
candy and we actually got zero responses.
And I was like,
well,
that's kind of weird because when I had
first opened the first couple of years,
every time I would put out an out, I
would get like 30, 40 applications. Um,
and I put out a second one in,
a couple of people trickled
in and thankfully one stuck
around and we hired them.
But it didn't make any sense to me.
I have a very niche cuisine and there's
enough vegetarian chefs out there and
we're well known enough restaurant that
we should have been getting a lot more.
Um, you know, there's only so
many vegetarian restaurants,
but a lot of vegetarian chefs.
So that was sort of making me think
there's something weird going on. Um,
and I started, you know,
asking all my chef friends,
like if they were noticing the same
problems and they're like, oh yeah,
we're having the hardest
time getting cooks. Um, and
what I sort of realized was,
oh yeah, of course. How there's
no cooks left in New York City.
There was a lot of cooks in cooking
schools or students training to be cooks,
but they're all going to other cities.
It's really expensive for them to live
in New York and they're traveling,
you know,
an hour,
an hour and a half to get to their job
where they're working 14 hours and then
traveling back.
And you know,
the standard Perry is about $10
for a prep cook or line cooking.
You move up maybe $12 and sort of the top
you hit is about 15 until you get like
very specialized. Um, but at 10, $12,
you can see really hard
to live in New York.
And so the students are going to other
cities and now have great restaurants,
there's great food seems everywhere
else and a higher standard of living.
It's easier. So I was like, ah, well I
have to fix this because I'm, you know,
in the back of my mind like,
Oh,
I'm about to open a new restaurant
and I'm going to need 15 more cooks,
what am I going to do? Obviously
the natural response is, well,
I have to pay them more and
that's how I'll get, you know,
attract them to the restaurant. But the
restaurant doesn't make that much money.
So margins in restaurants are really,
really small.
Even like the best restaurants,
maybe it's like 5%. Uh,
most restaurants were to hover around
3%. I run a crappy one, so it's like 1%.
Um,
but there's just,
the money just isn't there and we need a
lot of labor for the kind of food I do.
So I was like, okay, well
I have to find more money,
but I can't charge more for what I do.
Cause consumers were only pay so much. Um,
and they all right, I, I've
got to find this money.
And then I sort of started looking around
and I looked at my server who I loved.
Um, but she was the only one who
was allowed to take home tips.
And because we were a small restaurant,
it's 18 seats and check
average was about $100.
And if you're doing 60 people
a night and you're, you know,
you're pulling in a lot of money and 20%
of that is she's walking out with about
$600 a night on top of the minimum wage.
And I'm paying her. Um, so I was like,
oh my God, there's a huge discrepancy.
My line cooks are walking out with 120,
150, and she's walking out with 600.
It doesn't mean that, I don't think
that she wasn't working really hard,
but somehow bad.
Does it make sense if we're all working
towards the same goal in the restaurant?
So I was like, well, maybe, you know,
I'll just have my cook serve
more of my cooks helped.
They were always helping serve and my
dishwasher was helping serve more and I
was helping serve,
but none of us can touch the tips.
So that is like this law that
if you accept the tip credit,
even without the tip credit,
that the only person who can,
uh,
receive a tip is the server because
they touch the food basically 80% of the
time, once it's left the kitchen. And
that's how it sort of gets divided.
So then I was like, oh, well ha,
I can't take her tip money away back to
legal and I don't want to go to jail. Um,
I wouldn't do well in jail.
Um, uh, so I was like,
okay,
well I have to figure this out.
And then I started researching into
tipping and it's a really bad system.
It's sexist,
it's racist.
And it's kind of a false premise
because everybody's like, oh yeah,
well if services really bad, you
know, then I'm not going to, you know,
I'm going to cut my tip and half.
But the truth is,
is most people just tip what they tip.
You know,
if you're a 20% tip or your 20% tip, good
tip, spat, good service, bad service,
you do 15, you're 15 across the board.
Um, and then I started thinking, you know,
this is even weirder,
that I'm basically just letting my,
my customers be my human resources
department for my server.
Like they're the ones who are starting
to deciding what she gets paid and how
does this even make sense?
Because if I have a bad night,
it's the server that's going
to get punished, you know,
and when services really slow
and the food is really bad,
you blame the server,
you don't necessarily play in the kitchen.
And just all these sort of, uh, points
came together in my head. I was like,
alright, you know what?
Let's get rid of tipping.
Let's see if we can make this work.
And it was a really good time because
minimum wage is actually going up for
servers and for a regular
employees. So, you know,
I had to figure out how I was gonna be
able to pay them more. Uh, and yeah,
so that's how, that's how we
came to it. We started it.
Um,
it was pretty amazing how much people
really hated the idea that we were getting
rid of tipping.
Uh,
I've been pretty vocal about a lot
of things that they don't like in the
industry,
but nothing has like made people crazier
and hate me more than getting rid of
tipping. Um, I'm just like,
I'm stealing from my servers.
The bartenders aren't going to make any
money. How can I make this decision? Um,
I had, this is, this is one of, of these
sort of strange things that came out,
but I have never got as much antisemitic
hate now as from let us except from
this.
And when I didn't even know this,
like really actually existed
when I was like, oh my gosh,
like you people are saying
mean things about me. Um,
and you know, they're like, oh, you're so
cheap. You're so awful. And I was like,
well,
I'm not actually cheap.
I'm actually trying to be
really nice to my staff and,
and a lot of eds that are restauranters
where like, oh, it's never going to work.
Uh, and then so happened that it did
work. Uh, we haven't gotten rid of it.
Danny Meyer then also went
to his hospitality included,
which really helped us because it sort
of cemented the fact that, you know,
this is the way we think we're going to,
the restaurant industry is going to move
to my back of host, was really happy,
they get paid and my front of House,
uh, is pretty happy. You know,
we get the people who want to work for
a salary basically you can, you know,
we are guaranteeing them,
yes,
they could maybe make $300 one
night and another restaurant,
but they're also never going to
have a night where they make $100.
So it really sort of evens out in the end.
Uh,
and then we did decide to profit share
because I feel like for everybody,
you need a little incentive.
Uh,
raises are sort of far and
few between and restaurants,
especially for the front of House.
And we wanted to make it more fun and
we wanted them to really understand the
economics and have everybody feel like
they were working for the restaurant.
So we share 10% of our
profits when we have it.
We don't always actually have a 10%.
Uh,
but we do our best and we have lots
of little incentives along the way.
That's awesome.
So what's next?
What's on the next horizon of changing
the, you know, restaurant landscape?
I Dunno. Um, it's a tough one. I don't, I
don't know what really is out there next.
Um, you know, we have a,
we have a really big problem
in the city right now. Uh,
restaurants are exactly
sustainable as are, uh,
minimum wage is going to go up and I,
in the next couple of years that's from,
it's not going to help the tiny
margins in restaurants. Uh,
rents are incredibly expensive.
We're just operating a business in the
city and it's still really hard to find
labor no matter how much I'm trying to
pay my staff, they're just not here. And,
uh,
we've sort of had this restaurant's don't
charge enough money for the food they
serve. I know they seem
really expensive. A lot of,
a lot of labor goes into it
and it's really hard to get
people to understand how
much it cost, eat in a restaurant.
And you know, we all think,
oh well this plate of, um, you
know, those carrots, sliders,
if everybody came to the
cafeteria, oh, you know,
it's $12 and that's
just a carrot on a bun.
But the reality is it's way more
work than just a carrot on a button.
And on top of that,
I'm not only paying for that Labor,
but I'm also paying for the
toilet paper in the bathroom.
And you all want toilet paper
when you come to a restaurant. Um,
I certainly know that people
who steal it won it. So, uh,
and you also want electricity and
you want heat in the winter and air
conditioning in the summer.
All of that is really what you're paying
for when you go to a restaurant. Um,
and Eh, we don't charge enough. So we have
to figure out a way where we can start,
you know, convincing the consumer that
they have to pay a little bit more money.
And because if not,
restaurants are going to start to closing
what you'll end up with as a lot of
those sort of quick service
restaurants that, you know,
fine dining will disappear and that sort
of the next challenges unfortunately or
fortunately, I don't know, it's
educating the consumer a lot more.
Do you think that that's kind of the
solution right now just to educate the
consumer? Do you have like, I mean, that's
only sleeping. I know. I tried my best,
you know, I've, I'm trying so hard
to parent pay my staff a fair wage.
I want to be able to pay
them more in two years. Uh,
everybody who walks into the
restaurant starts off at $50 an hour.
Unless you're a server where
you make a little bit more. Um,
and in a couple of years that's actually
just going to be minimum wage, you know,
so I now have to figure out a way where
I can pay them $20 an hour. I can,
you know, get that up. I have to be
able to charge more for the food.
I have to find the money somewhere. Um,
so yeah, that is the only solution I know.
Yeah, that would definitely, um,
would love to shift gears a little
and talk about your cookbook.
So what made you decide to one write a
cookbook but to make it a comic graphic
novel cookbook? Well, um,
I really didn't really want to write a
cookbook and I had worked for a number of
restaurants where sort of within the
first year the chefs had disappeared to
write a cookbook. And I
was like, ah, that's not,
that sucks cause you're not there and
nobody's taking care of the restaurant.
And the restaurant really hadn't been
around enough, I thought to tell a story,
but I'm also a snob and have a lot
of opinions. What do I know? So, uh,
we had gotten approached a couple of
times by some editors and publishers that
were like, oh, we really
want you to write a cookbook.
We really want you to write a
cookbook. And was like, no, no, no.
And then sort of one day it's in, and
I was like, well maybe. And I was like,
but I don't, I don't want to write a
regular cookbook. Um, you know, I'm not,
I, I love cookbooks and
I have a huge collection,
but I'm not sure if people actually
cook from cookbooks so much anymore.
You know,
there is the Internet,
I think most people look online for
recipes and that's where they really cook
from. And cookbooks have become more
like a picture of books and you know,
coffee table books.
And I was like,
that's not really representative of
what we do with the reps restaurant and
we're going to do a cookbook. We have
to make something really fun. So I had,
I don't know,
uh,
I was having some huge fight
with my husband and he was like,
are you going to do this? I'm
like, I don't want to do this.
It's not going to be fun. And he's like,
well, let's make it fun. I was like,
I don't know how to make it fun.
I was like,
we'd have to do something really
stupid. And he was like, yeah,
like do it in a comic book form.
And then we both stopped dead and we
actually started over having the street
fight in the middle of the street.
So traffic had stopped
and we stopped and we were like, oh
yeah, that's perfect. And it just,
it clicked right away because
we knew that we could,
if we found the right artist,
we could really capture the spirit
of the restaurant in this book.
Little dirt candy was crazy.
It was insane.
And it was like a circus
every single night. And I,
I couldn't figure out how I could
just, you know, do that in pictures,
but with sort of the movement that you
get in a graphic novel, uh, we really,
we were like,
oh yeah,
we could really make this happen and we
can make these characters come alive and
we could tell the story of the restaurant
and then we could also sort of a
rework how recipes were written.
Uh,
I think it's really easy
to learn something visually
and not always when there's
a lot of words next to it, especially
with cooking. And we were like, Oh yeah,
we could draw out so much of this and
make it seem so real that it would make a
lot of sense to the person who's cooking
from it. And these aren't easy recipes.
So we really wanted to make them as
easy as possible for the reader. So we,
we went back to all the
editors and publishers who
had come to us and we're like,
oh, we're totally going to write a
cookbook. We have this great idea.
And they're like, no, absolutely not.
We're like, no one is going to be on.
And they were like, no way too much
work. And, uh, we found, uh, uh,
Clarkson potter, Random House,
say they took us on and, uh,
we worked with them to do
this and it was amazing. It,
I am not an artist whatsoever.
Uh, but Ryan, Dan Levy,
who is the graphic artist,
he did this amazing job of just really
capturing the essence of the restaurant
and making it like look alive and fun.
And we told the story through it and,
um,
everybody said that it wouldn't sell.
And so our first run I think
was about 5,000 copies, uh,
and within a month we had gone into the
second run and we're about 40,000 copies
now. Which for a cookbook
without a, you know, a big
name attached to it. It's good.
No, it's all, I still haven't made
back any royalties though yet.
Maybe after this. Uh, no.
That's awesome. So, uh, we
also know you were on iron
chef as mentioned before.
How was that experience?
What like what is the four one,
one inside scoop that they
don't show you on food network?
Um, the actually the, the biggest
surprise was how long it took,
not the battle.
The battle is real.
It's up that 60 minutes and it is crazy.
I don't remember most of it because
it happened in such a blur. Um,
but the judging takes a really long time.
So it's,
it's actually like four hours and
you're like, by the end you're like,
I don't care who wins.
I just want to go home and you're
some 7:00 AM I want to go home.
Um, it's pretty, the whole
experience was pretty crazy.
I sorta like everything in my life.
I said no to it.
And then they were like, are you sure?
And I was like, I don't know what.
I'm just going to go and look like
a loser and I'm going to lose.
And they're like, no you're
not. I was like, yeah, I
probably am a, and I was like,
I don't want to look dumb
and I don't want, you know,
we had to agree that it would
definitely be a vegetarian battle. Um,
and you know,
you get there and you know,
it's just a lot of bright lights and
camera people like all around you.
And the hardest thing is at the iron
chef really knows where everything is.
You know, they've been there, they've
done it, they're allowed in the kitchen.
So you know, they stock their fridges
the way they want to stock it.
They know how the stoves work and the
blenders work and just like the ice cream
machine and as the competitor,
you walk in and you're like, ah,
I don't know where's the fridge? And
they're like, not thing like I want,
that was the freezer.
I thought that was a stolen,
none of them really makes sense. So when
those 60 minutes, when you're cooking a,
you're looking for things half the
time it's like, ah, where am I? Um,
and you're doing that as some camera
guy is following you around for like,
I feel crazy. And then
the iron chef, you know,
they know where everything is
and so they're very calm. Uh,
I did exactly what they told
me I was going to do, which
is they're like, oh yeah,
you're the chef so you probably
don't cook a lot. I was like,
I'm in my kitchen every night. And
they're like, yeah, just be careful.
You're probably gonna cut yourself.
Cause I of got going to caught myself
like two seconds into it. I was like,
my fingers hanging off.
Um,
and then the whole,
you know,
show I had bandaids that kept falling
off and I was like, it stopped bleeding.
I can keep the bandaid off. And they're
like, no continuity. I was like, ah.
So like every three seconds I had a
new band aid on a stick to the plot.
And then for us, the,
we're dumb. All of us just,
I love my people who work in my
restaurant but me included. But we just,
we didn't quite get what we were supposed
to do. And um, you know, they were like,
well, it's five courses. And we're like,
yeah, it's five courses and I don't,
I don't know what was actually
wrong with our brains. Um,
but we made enough food for like a
night in the dining room, but it really,
it's only like the judges who sit there
and it's like three people taking tiny
little bites. They were all like
amuse sites, just amuse boosh sites,
tiny little size. Then you realize that's
really what, uh, uh, chef Morimoto did.
They make these tiny little portions.
Meanwhile we'd made it like gallon
of burble on sauce and they're like,
what are you going to do with all this
butter sauce? I'm like, I don't know,
put it on craigslist.
So we spend a lot of time doing stupid
stuff like that. And I would like to say,
Eh, that we won, but we did not win. But
we did a good showing and it was fun.
I would never do it again. I'm not
a competitive person like that, uh,
but it was really, really fun to do
and I'm glad I have it on my resume.
That is awesome.
What a cool story.
So we'll actually be taking
questions in the next few minutes.
So if anyone has a question, start to
think about it and head to the mix. Um,
would love to just hear
a little quick fire. Uh,
what is the best thing you've ever eaten?
I hope I haven't eaten it yet.
Oh,
what is your favorite vegetable and why?
I know it's like all your kids.
I actually,
this is an onion. It's actually my
favorite vegetable. It's really,
really versatile and it's the
backbone of almost every single dish.
So we couldn't live without
it in the kitchen. I mean,
I don't usually eat them
like an APP. They're really
sweet, but that is, you know,
it,
it works so hard in the kitchen
and it gets such little love,
I guess the Grayson, any, uh, particular
onion that you like better than others or,
oh, no, I'm, I'm, I'm an onion lover.
What's your favorite thing to do?
To relax and actually just
read a book by myself.
Not Talk to anybody. That's
awesome. Okay, cool. Well,
any questions looks like we do have one.
I, so what are the tax implications
of the gratuity only model?
And I was also curious if you see any way
of changing the laws to make it easier
for restaurants to do what you're doing
in that, in that regard. Uh,
the tax implications, uh,
for me personally as a business,
um,
they're divided on third doesn't
make a big difference. I have,
my insurance has gone up a lot because
my payroll has gone up a lot. Uh,
so that's the biggest difference.
Like cost to me,
tax implications are for the consumer
because now you're getting taxed on your
tip. All right, so sales tax for
the consumer has gone up. Uh,
but it's also only gone up slightly
because you used to pay sales tax on let's
say the hundred dollar portion of your
bill and now you're paying it on 120,
but it's really, it's only that
differential on the $20. Right? Um,
the laws to the laws are there to
make what I'm doing actually best for
everybody.
The laws surrounding tipping
are so complicated and like
even without meaning to
people break them constantly and it's,
it's like funny things
you wouldn't think of. Um,
bussers this is sort of what most of the
law states, if you've ever, if you know,
read the sort of, I don't know, food
gossip papers and you know, there's a lot,
all of these lawsuits against restaurants
and tipping and who gets paid what,
well,
the easiest way to understand that is
bussers who spend more than 20% of their
time polishing or not until I
entitled to the tips. I mean, that's,
and that's part of their job, right? So
thank you have to be like, okay, you know,
Rizal you've been punked polishing for
an hour and you've got to get back on the
floor. I'm got to switch you off with
somebody else. And even he's like,
but I liked doing the polishing.
He's not entitled to the tips. Um,
so the law actually works against tipping.
It works great for exactly what I'm doing,
which is parent paying everybody a fair
wage and not having to sort of be a part
of that, uh, tipping system.
The,
it would be nicer if,
um,
yeah,
like the way we do get hit a little ways
on are like state taxes for employees
like food and Sudan.
That it'd be nice if those were reduced
a little because everybody's, we're,
we're getting hit with that.
And if, um, you know, uh,
there was some, if you weren't
part of the tip credit system,
if there was some other credit system,
but you were paying your
employees a fair wage.
Very interesting. Cool. Hi.
I was wondering if you could talk
a little bit about vegetarianism,
both kind of your personal philosophy
towards it and then the role that you
think it kind of plays in the or should
play in the food scene in general,
especially as they are kind of more
vegetarian vegetable focused restaurants
opening.
Um, well, I'm not a vegetarian,
so I was one for about,
uh, maybe, um, 15 years or so.
Uh,
and I gave it up because I did,
I had gone to, I was really tired of
the vegetarian plate, a restaurant,
to be honest.
And I was like,
I can't eat any more grilled
Portabello and a side of rice,
even at like fancy restaurant, you know,
I'm, I'm not, if I'm going out to eat,
I'm really not becoming a better
chef. And if I'm, you know,
this obviously other staffs just really
care about the protein on the plate and
not the vegetables. That was about 15
years ago. Uh, and times have changed,
so, but for me, that's, you know, I'm
not a vegetarian anymore and I was,
I really only became a vegetarian because
I don't like meat. It's so there's no,
it's just a personal taste preference.
I've never really missed it.
Uh,
I do think the world's a diet is changing.
I think people want to
eat more vegetables.
I still think they really want to eat
meat and it's all about finding the
balance. So I think restaurants
like mine that are uh,
really vegetable focused are always
going to be a smaller proportion of the,
you know, the restaurants out there. Uh,
but the more people can offer vegetables,
the more exciting it is.
And we're starting to see some
really exciting things happen,
particularly in New York City,
uh,
where people are now getting used to
eating their vegetables are restaurants.
It doesn't seem so awful.
Yeah.
What's your favorite dish
on your menu right now? Um,
what was the last Oh,
well probably the carrot sliders,
which is what we serve downstairs.
And uh,
also we have this eh pepper
dish and which is delicious.
But mostly I like it cause it's really,
really annoying to my staff to have,
to make you have to do it.
And then we take bell peppers and uh,
we filet them.
So we peel off one side of the scan and
peel off the other and then we punch a
lot of holes out of it.
So they look like lifesavers and it's a
lot of work and they were really angry
at me. So that's like,
I find that pleasurable.
Awesome.
We'll take a question.
Yeah.
So dirt candy is a really
great name for a restaurant.
This focused on vegetables.
I wonder if you had any sort of story
about how you came up with that name and
its origins.
Well, again, it was a fight
between my husband and I. So, uh,
we were, we were tying to figure out
what to name the restaurant and um,
we, we wanted to stay
away from a one word, uh,
restaurant name really,
because this is weird to say here,
but because it's really hard
to Google it. Um, you know,
if you're called fork and you just put
in for like everything shows up from
actual forks,
so like a fork in the road,
like a million other
restaurants named fork. Um,
so that was out Andy and we were
trying to really figure out,
um, you know, what, what
the restaurant represented,
what vegetables rep represented and,
and you know,
as things escalate, we were fighting
about what they meant and what they were.
And at one point I was like, no,
they're like candy from the earth.
And my husband was like,
like dirt candy.
And we both stopped and we were like,
Oh yeah, dirt candy. That's good.
That's really, really good.
And then before we had opened,
we thought we were going to be more of
like a vegetable and fruit restaurant.
So we're like, well, if we
call ourselves dirt candy,
we can be dirt candy and tree meat.
I know we both stopped and we're like,
no tree meets, call a restaurant.
[inaudible] I'll know.
I still really like it.
Um, and then we sort of went from there.
We were like, yeah, dirt candy. It's,
it's perfect. Um, and then I actually
went to go buy dirt candy, the name, uh,
and it was taken,
that's why I'm dirt candy nyc.com.
And it actually pulled up
my other favorite name,
not necessarily for a restaurant,
but for a project that
one day I want to work on,
which is nasty bond bond song calm,
which would be this like the sister to
dirt candy. So I, I should have bought it.
I really like that nasty bond bonds.
And then so we took their candy and we
knew it was going to be a difficult name
for some people. And we did, I mean
still to this day, eight years later,
two restaurants, uh, and you
know, countless reviews. Uh,
we are still getting the last of the
worst name for a restaurant. I'm like,
I don't really care cause you remember
it and you will never forget it.
And so that's, you know, we
branded ourselves with this name.
How do you deal with,
you know,
criticism and people constantly
critiquing your food?
I cry a lot. I find myself
in the bathroom. Um,
I try not to read the reviews and then
I'm totally lying cause I read them,
which everybody does.
I know other people who read them and
they sort of filter it out for me. Uh,
and we, you know, it's,
the truth is it's hard.
It's really hard. We all work really hard.
I'm in the restaurant every single day.
My team is in the restaurant
and we have staff meetings.
We do our best to do customer service.
We're constantly asking people, uh,
how things are or what
else we can do for them.
And when you read something the next day,
um,
where you know, it's really negative
and you're like, but I was right there,
you know, just why didn't
you say something to me in
person where I can fix it?
I can't fix it. If you've left, really,
I can, you know, offer to, you know, uh,
refund your meal if I can get an
email address or a phone number.
But the truth is I want to
help you there. My, my goal,
even though I am a chef and yes, I have
an ego, is I'm a restaurant or in my,
I want to give you the best customer
service possible and I want to make sure
you have the best experience and such a
small part of going to a restaurant is
about the food.
It's about the company and the service
and everything else that makes it up and
that's my job is to make you really,
really happy.
Hopefully I can make you love the food
to you might not like it and that's okay.
Not My food is definitely not for
everybody, but the experience is,
you know what I want you to have
and it's really, really hurtful.
Actually when we read negative reviews
can we're like, well we're right there.
You could defend something. You thought
this was too salty. I'm so sorry.
We would remade it or you
didn't like this or you know,
you thought you weren't getting paid
enough attention. Whatever the thing is,
I can only fix it at the moment.
And that's, you know for sure.
Definitely.
First of all, the carrots flutters
were really good. How do I for lunch,
so thank you for that.
It was super delicious and I'm next,
I was thinking about all the challenges
of having a restaurant in New York City
that you talked about how expensive
it is and how hard it is to get stuff.
I'm wondering if you ever think about
leaving New York and setting up shop
somewhere else and if you don't,
why you stay in New York City
and if you do where you'd go?
Um,
I stay because I have a 10
year lease I can't get out of.
Also, I, you know, I live
here, this is my home.
I've been here for over 20
years. I love, love the city. Uh,
but it wasn't this hard beforehand
and it's become really hard and really
expensive over the last
couple of years. Um, and
I, I probably will never open
another restaurant in New York City.
It's just financially, I don't know
how people afford to do it, really. Um,
uh, so if I were to go to somewhere
else, I would probably go home.
I'd probably maybe, you know,
open another place in Toronto,
which is where my entire family is.
So it would be nice to
spend some time with them,
but I'm not sure I want to
ever open another restaurant.
And so it's a lot of work and
I, you know, I'm getting old.
I don't want to stand that
long anymore. Um, you know,
I've been standing for 15 hours a day
for about 20 years. I'm tired. Uh,
restaurants are really,
really hard work.
So it's been fascinating.
As someone who likes going to restaurants
to hear about your experiences and
your opinions,
it was really curious about what you
think about takeout and delivery because
that's like a big thing. I wonder what
you is a restaurant. I think about that.
I mean I think it's great cause I eat
it when I'm not working all the time,
so thank goodness for seamless.
I don't know what I would do. Um,
you know, it's, it's almost
like takeout and delivery.
It's like there's two different dudes.
It gets like they don't,
they're not the same. We can't
do delivery from dirt candy. Um,
because our portions only looked
normal sized in the restaurant.
I don't know if it's because
of the plane size or what,
but he to talk it up and tell me, it's
like, I'll take that to go rob. He's like,
Huh, how did that fit in that tiny
little container, three weeks making it.
Um, so it is really, really different.
Uh, I missed sorta like the Taiko model
though and delivery and all those sort of
like quick service.
Restaurants are great and they have found
this way to make portions decent size.
They get you through fast enough and it
sort of at satisfying comfort moment,
but it's really, really different
than going out to eat in a restaurant.
And I do think because people,
uh, especially in New York,
there is so much takeout and delivery,
um,
it changes your expectations
at a restaurant.
You forget that you're
there for the experience.
And to me there with company and to
have a bottle of wine or cocktails or
whatever it is and uh, you know, really
sit and enjoy the moment versus, you know,
getting something really fast and eating
it at your desk or in front of the TV
and being finished with it.
Um,
and because there's so many takeout
and delivery kind of places it has,
I do think change the way people,
even restaurants.
Yeah,
for sure.
Any other questions before we wrap up?
Go for it.
Oh wait, what's your goto
seamless order? I have to ask. Um,
problem. Well, we had a
lot of fights about it.
You know what, I'm tired of. Every time
we find a restaurant and we really like,
I swear like the next week it's gone.
What happened to you?
Uh, we have a Thai place on her
corner, but it's pretty good.
And then I feel really bad
saying if on our corner I'm like,
how can I not go out and pick it up
myself? It's like a block and a half away,
but I'm still like, no,
you're going to come.
That was wondering whether as running a
vegetarian restaurant and you feel that
there's a pricing pressure where customers
in New York are willing to pay more.
If there's a fancy piece of meat
on the plate, then they will,
if you put even more Labor into making a
really nice vegetable, but B, they say,
oh, it's just a vegetable.
I don't need to pay for it.
Are you in my brain? Yeah,
I mean that's actually,
I think one of the really big
problems with the restaurant. Um,
we sort of have this price price point.
We can't go above,
which is like $22 $23.
And if that's sort of the cutoff point
after that, we will see in reviews. I go,
I'm not going to pay
that much for this food.
But I do think if I had that
same dish at a steak house,
I could probably charge $30 and nobody
would sort of think twice about it.
It is where you're eating and what
sort of getting served next to it.
One of the really hard things
with vegetables, and this
is my fault and you know,
it's my restaurant, it's what
I do. But they are revealing,
labor-intensive and like,
can you think like, oh,
I put a whole piece of meat in
the oven and I just cook it. Well,
every single carrot has to be peeled
and diced and cooked and done something
else to it. Um, and so that,
that Labor difference is huge.
Like people will walk into my
kitchen and be like, oh my God,
there's so many of you here. I'm like,
I know, I'm so embarrassed. I'm like,
why am I embarrassed? Um, so just that,
that difference. Yeah, I mean if I, I,
I truly believe if I put a
piece of fish on my menu,
I can raise all my is by a couple of
dollars and November when we were like,
yeah, of course she serves
six. Nobody would order it,
but I hate that I would
have it. I'm like, oh,
it's not fish restaurant with lots of
vegetables you can charge $30 a plate.
What's your view on,
yeah,
local produce versus organic produce.
I feel like a lot of the times
now it's a lot of farm to table.
Do you feel like that's a really important
element to have in a restaurant or
your a restaurant or do you, are
you comfortable with, you know,
any type of veteran?
I'm comfortable with any type
of vegetable. Uh, we, if you,
if you can afford it and you want
to buy organic grape, I can't,
my prices would be ridiculously
high. Uh, we do some organic stuff.
A lot of our dairy is half
of our dry goods, but, and,
and certain produce items. But
for the most part, we're not, eh,
local when it's in season.
Great. But you know,
we live in the northeast
and even in, you know, I,
I wrote a whole piece about tomatoes and
how it's, you know, if you want it to me,
no, just go buy it. It's don't
feel guilty, better needed tomato,
then something else in
the middle of winter. Um,
all food comes off a truck
in a box somewhere anyways.
Uh, we have a big enough problem in this
country that people don't eat enough
vegetables. Uh, New York might be
sort of outside of that, but you know,
the f a USDA statistics for how
much vegetables or eating really,
really depressing in this country.
And the two most popular vegetables are
potato and tomato because it's French
fries and ketchup. And
so like, I'm like, yeah,
I'm not sure local is the issue. I'm just
getting people to eat vegetables. Um,
so yeah, when we can, we buy local,
but we can't always, and you know, my,
my goal is to get people to eat their
vegetables and once I can get them to do
that, maybe I'll try a little harder
with other things. Cool. Awesome.
We'll take one more question.
Yeah.
Um,
I live in the lower east side.
I was wondering if you could talk
a little bit about, uh, sort of,
it's your choice of vocation and kind of
the restaurant scene in lower east side
and sort of how you feel it compares to
other parts of the city and stuff. Like
I've only ever owned a restaurant in
the East village or the lower east side,
totally different neighborhoods
and they're actually very similar.
Uh,
the,
the thing with the lower east side is
it's probably one of the last areas where
you can get a good deal on rent.
And that's why I chose it. Um, it's,
you know, rent is really
expensive in New York right now.
So for my small space, which
was 350 square feet, uh,
my rent started off at $1,800,
which was really fair and decent and
eight years later it was that 4,000.
Wow. So those numbers just
don't make any sense. No.
10 blocks south, which is where
I am in the lower east side. Um,
I have about 2,500 square
feet and my rent is 10,000.
So that makes a lot more sense.
And married,
you can still get a really a good
rent deals. The restaurant scene,
I think in the lower east side,
east side is the most exciting.
The restaurants were really nice.
Um, I love being the spillage. Oh No,
they were mean over there.
Nobody wanted to take my broccoli.
Jewelries. Sigh. Everybody's
taking it now. They're really nice.
We have a really nice community of
restaurants and I think the food scene is
exciting and I think because
the rents are cheaper, um,
and you can sort of make a living,
people are more willing to take chances.
And so it's a lot of fun. There's
this, this really young, vibrant, uh,
feeling down there. Other neighborhoods
in the city to me seem really stagnant.
It seems like it's the same
restaurant opening over and again,
and I think in the lower east side
and you got to see a little bit more
diversity.
Super Cool.
All right,
well that is it.
Everyone should go stop by dirt candy and
make a reservation at 86 Allen Street.
Um, we also have some comic
book cookbooks for sale.
Google or discount for $5 so feel
free to grab one after the talk.
Amanda,
thank you so much for coming.
The food was amazing and I know I can
speak for myself and everyone else.
This talk has been awesome getting
know. Thank you. Thank you.